how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body but none for the
soul not only does it encourage you to
read it tells you how many verses you've
read how many pages you read how long
you've been on it and best of all the
hasana counter download the qurani app
now
brothers and sisters and dear friends if
somebody asked me to summarize Islam in
a nutshell I would say besides tawheed
it is the bitter truth what do I mean by
that brothers and sisters Islam gives
you the medicine that is bitter in the
mouth but it's the truth brothers and
sisters and it is good for us and that
is that is exactly the reason why Brown
sisters I've changed my whole set and
I've got so much more to open to open up
to you guys about about my life and many
things I'll be covering on this specific
show on this new set and more new sets
to come today's video is specifically
about as you guys know what happened in
Leicester me and Muhammad hijab was
observed were observing what was going
on Leicester from the cricket match to
the Hindus
BJP RSS extremist group coming to
Leicester provoking Muslims stabbing
individuals attacking Muslims and many
many more by provoking us the point what
I'm trying to say is this bone sisters
we went there and we went there
purposely why to support our brothers
and sisters no muslim likes to see
another Muslim being attacked yes
specifically being provoked we traveled
all the way there brothers and sisters
to the escalated situation and we was in
contact with some Community leaders one
of them was magic Freeman brothers and
sisters when we were there some
individuals were hostile towards us and
these are Muslim these are from our side
talking about you know
um recently we talked topics of
backstabbing Etc I mean literally on the
ground this is what was going on brother
and sisters we was there and this was a
small minority let's not twist it
majority of the Leicester Brothers
alhamdulillah greeted us and thanked us
and we are nobody problem sisters when
we come and do these things we don't
want to be labeled the hero we don't do
it for clout and may Allah forgive us if
we do we genuinely want to go there and
cover it because what I'm about to show
you with how the media has spun this
whole thing not towards myself even
though I went there with hijab but
specifically targeting hijab so the
point I want to make is this brothers
and sisters in my country they say
meaning if I spit up after my mustache
in the way if I spit down I've got my
beard in the way you are damned if you
do and you are damned if you don't they
have Twisted this whole thing to make it
out to be as if Muhammad
hijab is this is jihadist preacher hate
preacher he's stirring up hate that is
total opposite
but we come
play to that tune quite frankly us
breaking cars or running here running
there that's not going to help us how's
that going to help us
tell me how I'm not going to say to you
don't defend yourself you know from the
clips that you saw hijab specifically
said what will we get out of burning
cars or attacking individuals or
whatever it may be this is not the way
to go about it we came there with
strategic plans and we know that this
battle is forced not only in the March
but also in the media fund and there's
many funds to it that go all the way
back to India and what the Muslims are
suffering under this BJP RSS Hindustan
group who have ties and connections
um to individuals who have started this
who have been inspired by the Nazi
Germany by Hitler himself so brothers
and sisters we look at the smear
campaign against Muhammad by Daily Mail
the telegraph even Piers Morgan well
we're not going to say Piers Morgan
specifically said something but he
messaged Muhammad hijab now this shows
you for some of the individuals who was
accusing hijab and myself of clout
chasing
the telegraph the sun The Daily Mail
even Pierce Morgan himself in well
through his PA message Muhammad and ask
him to come on the show this would have
been a perfect opportunity for hijab to
jump on the bandwagon and just go and
for popularity whatever it may be he
categorically said no to every single
media Outlet
when it came to Piers Morgan he
specifically said to this PA to go into
a PS Morgan that hijab said no now I
said to my I said to myself and I was
speaking hijab bro why would you do you
are the perfect guy to dismantle them
you will deal with them and he said Aki
the risks are too high and the gains are
too low and I thought to myself Savannah
that's so true because when you go into
these these places brothers and sisters
they've recorded what they want to
record they put out what they want to
put out and that's exactly what they
were going to do and hijab saw it for
what it is and he said no to every
single one of them
the point I'm trying to say is the
double standards we are now called
jihadists islamists extremists before it
was called to a group of people who
would go and join a foreign group in
this area wherever it may be and they
would label this this
now as a Muslim activist myself Muhammad
anyone else happens to be the moment you
get involved in a peaceful protest and
you are there to de-escalate the
situation and to give some
um reminder to the youth to not go down
the route of taking Flags down of or
trying to attack um innocent Hindus Etc
which never happened but the uh the BJP
RSS group these individuals who when
they came they were attacking one of the
first people that attacked was a Sikh
man so you can see that even as Muslims
when we go to a peaceful protest we are
labeled an islamist or a jihadist or an
Islamic hate preacher what does one do
and this is where Allah says in the
Quran the disbelievers will never ever
be happy with you until you turn away
from your religion that is what they
want there is nothing that you can do
that they're going to say we're happy
with you now the only moment and the
only place they would say we are happy
with you now and even then and even that
they won't be happy with you is when you
come and say I have left Islam then
they'll be like okay now we love you now
we respect you now we open our hands to
you
and we say Keep Your Hands closed keep
what you want to give us away from us we
do not want nothing because what we have
is more than enough for us Allah and his
messenger alhamdulillah is more than
enough for us we do not need anything
you're going to give but the reason I'm
doing this video is to show the double
standards and the hypocrisy and how they
are trying to twist this thing to make
it out as if we Muslims came out they do
not even mention this group three to
four hundred of them marching and
provoking the Muslims and a Muslim boy
being stabbed nothing about it
so my dear brothers and sisters were
watching this Me Myself and hijab and
many other Duart inshallah we're not
just the only ones here okay we're not
trying to be heroes yeah we try our best
but we will be making sure that anytime
a Muslims oppressed or be it a Christian
or even if it's a Hindu or even if it's
Jewish you know my video I've gone to
situations where a Jewish man is
attacked on the road Justice is Justice
and Allah says in the Quran be just even
if it's against yourself be upholders of
Justice even if it's against yourself or
your own kin we will live by that
Justice and we ask Allah that we die on
that Justice and the media smear
campaign that they're doing against
hijab is nothing but an absolute lie and
the bitter truth is that Islam is the
truth and we know it's the truth